measles mumps rubella and many other
illnesses can all be prevented by a
quick jab in the arm
health officials say it saves the lives
of up to three million people per year
but they also say the work is being
threatened by a growing anti vaccination
campaign now scientists and doctors have
met in Brussels to fight back it is
unacceptable in the 21st century our
children are dying from diseases that
should not exist we have to put an end
to this intolerable situation it's
incumbent on each and every one of us
smallpox is no more thanks to vaccines
polio has been pushed to the brink of
eradication thanks to vaccines once fear
business-like diphtheria tetanus measles
and meningitis are now easily prevented
thanks to vaccines the World Health
Organization is pointing to what it
calls the myths about vaccines
they include diseases disappearing
before vaccines were introduced medical
professionals say vaccines have had a
significant impact and to the criticism
of most people who get diseases have
been vaccinated
waho says most are 85 to 95 percent
effective but only recently have we seen
a mass anti-vaccination movement and
it's probably to do with the social
media that that's become so important at
the moment in the way that people get
there there are news and know we have
something which is spreading very
rapidly which is out of control this
anti vaccination campaign group in
Washington DC says the freedom to decide
to vaccinate is a human right when you
take away a person's freedom and medical
choice mandating vaccines for education
that is couette coercion back in
Brussels
Fergal Brennan is seeking to continue
the advocacy work his sister did before
she died of cervical cancer
the voice of one girl can change
everything Laura passed away in March of
this year from cervical cancer a cancer
that is almost entirely preventable she
was 26 years old she dedicated the last
months of her life to raising awareness
of the importance of the HPV vaccination
she did it because if she had the HPV
vaccine in Spike Lee I would not be here
today she will be with us diagnosed at
17 confocal says his sister received
support but also abuse when she tried to
convince women to take the HPV
vaccination and he says it's fear based
on mistrust and misinformation that this
summit seeks to end Laura burden manly
al Jazeera